begin with russia's unrelenting bombing
campaign in ukraine this is the
aftermath of what appears to be a
russian missile strike that punched a
huge hole in a government building in
the south of the country the violence is
fueling skepticism about russian claims
that they will scale back military
operations in two areas this morning the
u.n said more than four million refugees
have now fled ukraine deborah patta is
in key for us deborah good morning
good morning now the pentagon insists
they are not calling the russian
military's claim to pull back from
around kiev and chernohiv a retreat but
are repositioning it's not clear exactly
what the russian intentions are but
around the capital the threat remains
high
boardroom negotiations mean little on
the battlefield ukrainians are not
letting their guard down
soldiers patrol checkpoints around the
capital kiev looking for the enemy
within searching for russian saboteurs
danger lurks on the ground
and in the sky when a drone flies
overhead this soldier raises his weapon
i'm on it he says
then takes aim
the enemy is still here said president
vladimir zelensky missile and air
attacks have not stopped
that's the reality
the port city of mario paul has all but
collapsed even if peace is given a
chance all that's left here is rubble
and ruin
kids want their childhood back
i'm so tired this little girl says and
my toys have no batteries in them
older men
just want to forget
what else can i do gennady asks there's
nothing left for me here
he's walking away after nearly 40 years
working as a shoemaker here
russian separatist fighters are in no
mood for peace forcing these ukrainians
to strip down claiming they're searching
for nazi tattoos
in nearby mikalive a russian rocket
ripped through a government building
leaving a gaping hole and fresh trauma
this woman watched helplessly as her
colleague died in her arms
even if the russian military makes good
on its promise to pull back from kiev
around the capital where fierce battles
have been raging there's nothing much
left to fight for and while ukraine
claims to have taken back nearby towns
like urban those areas have been
decimated many did not make it out alive
british intelligence says russian troops
are pulling back from kiev to belarus
and russia because they need to regroup
after suffering heavy losses and the
ukrainian government says they believe
russia will retain some troops near kiev
to keep the pressure on the capital and
prevent ukraine from sending its forces
to the eastern front where as you know
the war is still raging tony
indeed it is deborah pataforce and keith
deborah thank you very much